vamos a hacer un repaso de algunas de
las cosas que ya sabemos y esto nos va a
ayudar a entender mucho más cómo es que
una fracción la podemos ver como una
división y es que este tema es
importantísimo pero vamos a empezar con
algo un poco más sencillo para que tú
visualices a qué me refiero imagínate
que yo me tomo 22 y al 2 lo quiero
multiplicar lo quiero multiplicar por 4
vamos a multiplicar a dos por cuatro
bueno nosotros sabemos cuántos dos por
cuatro pero si lo vemos una manera
visual esto quiere decir que tenemos a
aquí al 2
tenemos dos bolitas en este caso y lo
que voy a hacer es tomarme cuatro veces
este par de bolitas por lo tanto han
dejado de ver si las puedo copiar a ok
vamos a copiarlas
y vamos a pegarlas lo que voy a hacer es
tomarme una de estas ok
dos de estas tres veces estas bolitas y
cuatro veces estas bolitas es decir que
lo que me estoy tomando cuando tengo 2
por 4 es 4 veces el conjunto aquí tengo
cuatro veces el conjunto de dos bolitas
y si te das cuenta dos por cuatro esto
es exactamente lo mismo que 8 que es la
cantidad de bolitas que ahora tengo aquí
abajo tengo 8 bolitas y bueno esto nos
da pie a pensarlo de la siguiente manera
si yo quisiera dividir vamos a ponerlo
aquí 8 ahora al 8 lo quiero dividir
imagínate que ahora lo queremos dividir
entre 4 vamos a dividir al 8 entre 4
ok pues realmente lo que nos quedaría y
para seguir con la idea de las bolitas
déjame ahora a agarrar estas bolitas de
aquí las voy a copiar todas
y las voy a pegar ok copiar y pegar ya
tengo aquí a todas las bolitas que tenía
justo acá y cuando yo divido el 8 entre
4 lo que quiere decir es que voy a hacer
4 montones iguales es decir que en este
caso no voy a tomar un montón tengo
estos atrapados ahora y vamos a ponerlo
con otro color y ahora me voy a tomar
otro otro de ellos
ok justo este ahora me voy a tomar otro
de ellos
justo este ok y para finalizar no voy a
tomar otro de ellos justo este estoy
divirtiendo a las 8 bolitas que tenía
justo aquí en cuatro grupos iguales y es
justo en ese momento que yo puedo
concluir que 8 entre 4 es exactamente lo
mismo que 2
2 y está de lujo podemos ver la
multiplicación también como una forma de
expresar la división ok y ahora qué te
parece si nosotros pensamos justo esto
pero utilizando fracciones imagínate
ahora que me voy a tomar a se me ocurre
tomarme un tercio un tercio ya un tercio
lo voy a multiplicar lo voy a
multiplicar por tres por tres que me va
a quedar de esto bueno pues imagínate
que tengo aquí a un entero y para esto
déjame hacer un rectángulo por aquí voy
a hacer un rectángulo por aquí tengo a
un entero completo ok ya este entero
lo voy a dividir en tres porque
solamente me voy a tomar un tercio así
que vamos a dividirlo en tres
ok y mediante que esta es una de las
partes éstas otra de las partes
ok más o menos así y solamente me voy a
tomar un tercio un tercio ok
cuando yo lo multiplique por tres eso
quiere decir que me voy a tomar tres
veces un tercio
aquí cuando yo tenía el 2 y lo
multiplique por cuatro méritos
4 veces 2 dicho de otra manera lo que
voy a hacer es tomarme un tercio ya esto
sumarle otro tercio sumarle otra tensión
ya esto sumarle otro tercio otro tercio
para que en total me tome tres veces un
tercio am y aquí tengo tres veces un
tercio y déjame ponerlo así tres veces
veces un tercio ok y si te das cuenta
tres veces un tercio llegamos a un
entero es decir acabamos de rellenar
completo este rectángulo que tengo aquí
por lo tanto puedo concluir que un
tercio por tres es exactamente lo mismo
que uno
ok ahora qué te parece si pensamos justo
en lo mismo pero en la opción contraria
voy a analizarlo justo como lo tenemos
acá arriba vamos a pensarlo de la
siguiente manera si yo me tomo el 1 ok
ya este uno lo divido lo divido entre 3
entre 3 eso quiere decir que me voy a
tomar a un entero completo y vamos a
ponerlo así lo voy a tomar a un entero
completo ok
va a ser este rectángulo de aquí me
entero completo ya este entero lo voy a
dividir entre 3 eso quiere decir que hay
que partir a este rectángulo de rojo que
tengo aquí justo en tres partes iguales
así que vamos a intentarlo o no no vamos
a intentarlo voy a ver a dividirlo en
una parte en dos partes ok ya tengo tres
partes iguales 1 entre 3 esto es
exactamente lo mismo que un tercio esto
no va a quedar igual a un tercio porque
solamente no voy a tomar una de estas
tres partes justo esta de aquí
y seguramente en este momento debe de
haber algo que está pasando por tu
cabeza que es sorprendente si yo me tomo
a un entero y lo divido entre 3 es
exactamente lo mismo que pensar 1 entre
3 visto con fracción un tercio aquí
tengo a este entero dividido entre 3 y
aquí tengo la fracción 1 sobre 3 por lo
tanto a un techo lo podemos ver también
como una división como la división de 1
entre 3 ok
bueno pues qué te parece si ahora
pensamos en otro caso tal vez un poco
más interesante para esto déjenme bajar
un poco la pantalla un poco solamente
vamos a bajarla hasta acá ok y ahora lo
voy a tomar lo siguiente qué te parece
si tenemos tres cuartos déjame cambiar
de color tres cuartos
lo voy a multiplicar lo voy a
multiplicar
por cuatro por cuatro bueno para eso
vamos a verlo también de una manera
visual y para esto déjenme hacer aquí a
un rectángulo voy a hacer aquí a un
rectángulo y lo voy a dividir en cuatro
partes iguales tengo aquí entre cuatro
así que vamos a dividirlo en cuatro
partes iguales supongamos que aquí tengo
una aquí tengo la otra ok y aquí tengo
la última ok por lo tanto tengo cuatro
partes iguales si yo lo quiero tomar
tres cuartos y multiplicarlo por cuatro
qué te parece si a esto este de aquí lo
voy a copiar porque lo vamos a ocupar
justo ahorita vamos a copiarlo ok y si
yo me tomo tres cuartos es justo de este
entero completo tomarme tres partes una
parte dos partes tres partes de estas
cuatro partes que tenemos dividido este
entero ahora si yo bajo un poco más la
pantalla vamos a bajar un poco más la
pantalla algo así ok
date cuenta que cuando yo lo multiplicó
por cuatro me estoy tomando cuatro veces
tres cuartos por lo tanto aquí tengo una
vez tres cuartos pero necesitamos tres
veces más así que déjame copiar y pegar
otra vez este de aquí lo voy a pegar
justo aquí y entonces date cuenta que
necesitamos una vez más otra vez lo voy
a utilizar con este color
un cuarto dos cuartos tres cuartos ok
aquí van dos veces tres cuartos pero yo
quiero cuatro por lo tanto déjame pegar
otra vez este rectángulo de aquí vamos a
pegarlo ok y entonces a esto le voy a
sumar a otro cuarto otro cuarto y otro
cuarto aquí tengo tres veces tres
cuartos pero yo lo que necesito son
cuatro veces tres cuartos así que para
eso me voy a tomar los últimos tres
cuartos éste de kim este de aquí y este
de aquí de tal manera que tres cuartos
por cuatro es uno entero dos enteros
tres enteros tres cuartos por cuatro es
lo mismo que 3
o dicho de otra manera lo podemos ver y
déjeme escribirlo con este color lo
podemos ver como cuatro veces tres
cuartos cuatro veces veces tres cuartos
tres cuartos de lujo ahora si nosotros
no pensamos como lo estamos visualizando
justo aquí de la manera contraria si yo
quiero dividir tres enteros tres enteros
lo quiero dividir lo quiero dividir
entre cuatro entre cuatro entonces que
me va a quedar
bueno pues tengo aquí tres enteros y lo
quiero dividir en cuatro partes iguales
así que si te das cuenta tengo aquí una
de estas cuatro partes iguales
tengo esta parte de aquí ok después me
tomaría otra sería esta de aquí
ok vamos a ponerlo con línea punteada
esta de aquí sería otra de estas cuatro
partes iguales ok
después tengo otra aquí justo esta de
aquí tengo otra más otra de estas cuatro
partes iguales y por último tengo esta
de rosa esta de aquí de color salmón que
es otra de estas cuatro
igual es por lo tanto estoy diciendo que
si yo me quiero tomar 3 entre 4 esto es
exactamente lo mismo que tres cuartos
utilizando la misma lógica tengo tres de
las cuatro partes en la que estoy
dividiendo cada uno de los enteros y de
igual manera quiero que esto lo veas
como una división 3 entre 4 es lo mismo
que tres cuartos y aquí tengo al 3
dividido entre 4 3 cuartos es lo mismo
que tres sobre 4 wow esto esta
sorprendente no